foreign
hey everyone and welcome to this new
video of Simply learn on proof of work
in blockchain in this video we're going
to cover all important Concepts and
components related to proof of work
first we will have a quick introduction
of blockchain and then we will
understand what is proof of work then we
will look into how it works and after
that we will explore why it is actually
needed
what are the issues faced by proof of
work and last we will look into the
blockchains working with proof of work
so without further delay let's get
started with the video but before that
let's have a quick introduction to
blockchain
the term blockchain refers to a
decentralized database that is made up
of sequential blocks that contain
recorded data the database is backed up
by a network of self-contained
participants known as nodes
now let's understand what is proof of
work
proof of work is a decentralized
consensus method that requires Network
participants to spend time solving an
arbitrary mathematical puzzle in order
to prevent the system from being hacked
it is widely used in cryptocurrency
mining for validating transactions and
Mining new tokens
it helps in the processing of
peer-to-peer transactions securely
without the need of a trusted third
party
it also requires huge amounts of energy
at scale which only increases as more
miners join the network
now let's have a look at how proof of
work works
the right to add new blocks to a
proof-of-work blockchain is provided to
individuals who are willing to expand
computational resources to solve
cryptographic issues
the participants competing to add new
blocks are referred to as minors and the
process is referred to as mining miners
are the ones who execute proof of work
miners use their computational power to
locate a valid block when a piece of
information such as a transaction needs
to be added to the blockchain this is
accomplished by locating a hash that
meets the network protocol specific
requirements in cryptography a hash is
the outcome of a hash function it
converts any format or size of data into
fixed size numbers
the protocol established a level of
mining difficulty that is
algorithmically adjusted so that the
time it takes to obtain a proper hash
averages about 10 minutes
miners can sometimes locate multiple
blocks that satisfy the protocol's
requirements at the same time and split
the chain in two
well because there can only be one
accurate chain the protocol must account
for these circumstances
miners will initially continue to mine
on both chains but once another block is
discovered on top of one of the two
prior blocks that chain becomes the
canonical chain and miners are
economically incentivized to discard the
other blocks
and one of the advantages of proof of
work blockchain in terms of security is
their resilience to civil attacks a
civil attack occurs when one player in
the network generates many false
identities in order to get an unfair
advantage over other network
participants who only have one identity
51 attacks occur when a single user
takes control of more than 51 percent of
the Network's resources and hence has
control over the adding of new blocks
well now we know how proof of work Works
let's dive down deeper and explore why
do we need proof of work
so majorly proof of work is required for
security and prod prevention as well as
Trust
proof of work is intended to prevent
users from printing coins they didn't
earn or from double spending
if users could spend their coins more
than once the currency would effectively
become worthless proof of work ensures
that independent data processors or
miners can't lie about a transaction
linking a block with the proof of work
hash of its predecessor results in
tamper resistance because the hash of
each block is an ingredient in the hash
of the following block any changes in
the chain will affect the final proof of
work hash as well as all Block hashes in
between so the deeper the altered block
the more computational effort needed for
tampering
the first Miner who discovers the proof
of work answers publishes the solution
to the rest of the network and when a
new block is discovered all nodes are
notified we check the answer twice
before moving on to the next block
and PS if correct the block miners earn
the transaction fees and the block
reward
the protocol only accepts the longest
chain as valid and authentic a fake
chain is Impractical in the long run
since the minus chances of receiving the
block reward are minimal other miners
will continue to extend the valid chain
quicker than the tampered chain over
time
so moving on let's have a look at the
other side of the coin as well as
understand some of the major issues with
proof of work
first it has a negative impact on the
environment second the 51 attack can be
used against it if miners gain control
of 51 of the hashing power they will be
able to determine what is true
aside from the enormous cost of price
there is no mechanism in place to punish
any malicious miners
and fourth because every node must
process every transaction it does not
scale properly while shortening the
network May boost efficiency it also
reduces security
and this was all about proof of work
let's explore the best blockchain
networks working with proof of work
Bitcoin is the largest and the very
first blockchain to adopt proof of work
and work with it ethereum is next
working with proof of work though it is
aiming to switch to proof of stake which
we will talk about in a coming video
then comes Bitcoin cash which is an
extension of Bitcoin and follows the
same structure thus it also works on
proof of work and then comes Litecoin
which is also an altcoin of Bitcoin and
then comes Monero another cryptocurrency
serving similar purposes as other
cryptos
well this is all about proof of work in
blockchain and we've almost reached the
end of this video if I missed anything
important please let me know in the
comments section well I hope you enjoyed
this video on proof of work in
blockchain and learn something new from
it and if you like this video then
please hit the like button and thanks
for watching this video and stay tuned
for more updates and videos from Simply
learn
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learning YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here